bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous ce matin sur arte france
quelle est votre analyse de la crise
postélectorale a en biélorussie quatre
jours de manifestations maintenant c'est
un régime qui est archaïque qui ne
correspond plus à ce que veulent les
peuples en europe et donc qu'après ces
élections dont le moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est qu'elles ont été falsifiés et
bien évidemment il ya un mécontentement
général du peuple du peuple biélorusse
d'autant plus que la candidate titres
annoncent qu'elles représenté
pratiquement toutes les sensibilités
biélorusse puisque elle était soutenue
par baba rico qui lui avait la
réputation d'être plutôt pro-russe parts
est kahlo qui lui avait la réputation
d'être pro occidental dans quel ya
véritablement une sorte d'unanimité dans
la contestation du régime de morts des
centaines de blessés et des milliers
d'arrestations qui sont les manifestants
qui descendent dans la rue contre
alexandre loukachenko a été réélu avec
80 % des voix pour un sixième mandat
est ce qu'il représente réellement
le peuple biélorusse c'est très
difficile à dire parce que d'abord n'y a
pas de sondages véritablement fiable
souvenez que tire annonce sky avait dit
que c'était 97% pour elle et 3% pour
paulo cash and co je pense que c'est
plutôt les intellectuels et la classe
moyenne des villes dans les campagnes on
vote on est légitimiste on va plutôt
pour nous cacher locaux la communauté
internationale elle dénonce une sévère
répression est ce que c'est une lecture
conforme à la réalité sur le terrain
forme alors c'est une impression très
sévère mais sais tu ne s'est pas une
répression j'allais dire du tiers-monde
j'ai vu qu'on avait récemment utilisé
des balles réelles
ça me paraît un peu exceptionnel il ya
eu un blessé
c'est un mode de répression très dure
mais qui restent encore dans les normes
à peu près dans les normes occidentales
emmanuel macron il s'est dit préoccupé
et s'est entretenu avec vladimir poutine
par téléphone demain l'union européenne
va réunir ses ministres des affaires
étrangères est ce que l'union européenne
et la russie peuvent s'entendre pour
tenter d'apaiser la situation et avoir
une médiation ma main
écoutez si j'ai vu que la pologne avait
proposé sa médiation
ça me paraît difficile parce que dans la
réalité la russie va plutôt bénéficié de
cette affaire puisque lukashenko pour
redorer en quelque sorte son blason
national patriotes nationalistes selon
les mots avaient s'était positionné à ce
d'une façon assez anti russe au départ
alors maintenant levé les ministres vont
européens vont se réunir
ils vont peut-être voter des sanctions
le paradoxe est que ceux qui vont être
les avocats des sanctions sont ceux là
même qui souhaiteraient que minsk
s'éloigne de moscou or en votant des
sanctions l'union européenne qui va
revenir au régime d'avantagés 2016
puisqu'il y avait des sanctions jusqu'en
2016 et minsk avait été récompensé en
quelque sorte pour son rôle dans le les
négociations de paix les négociations
d'ukraine processus de minsk d'ailleurs
comme il s'appelle donc minsk avait été
récompensé par la levée des sanctions il
va y avoir à nouveau des sanctions
quelles sanctions européennes vont
naturellement rapproché à nouveau minsk
de moscou mais si la crise
postélectorale sans livres ou est-ce que
cela peut mener le père
alors bien sûr c'est rien de bon mais la
biélorussie n'est pas exactement du
plein en ukraine il ya clairement un
très grand parti au bout une grande
partie du pays qui est pro occidental et
cie qui est plutôt pro-russe
du côté de la biélorussie c'est plutôt
une contestation générale y compris de
ceux qui sont pour le rapprochement avec
la russie ou la proximité avec la russie
c'est une contestation générale contre
le régime déchu
donc les troubles il y a à première vue
et dans un premier temps ne seront pas
nécessairement antirusse comme ils ont
été très rapidement en ukraine
donc en fait l'évolution interne du
régime
nécessitant pour moscou en tout cas un
suivi géopolitique très très soignée
l'opposante d'alexandre loukachenko qui
s'est réfugié en lituanie est-ce que la
solution à cette crise postélectorale ça
peut être justement à nouveau une
ouverture du dialogue politique en
biélorussie car la marge de manoeuvre
pour alexander alexandre loukachenko je
ne sais pas s'il a pris conscience du
fait que son 6e mandat est sans doute le
mandat peau j'imagine qu'il ya pas mal
de ses conseillers et à l'extérieur qui
lui conseille de modifier un peu son
format de gouvernement et d'associés en
tout cas c'est as moyenne au pouvoir je
ne sais pas s'il pourra le faire parce
que manifestement cessé ses réflexions
son mode de réflexion et et quand même
j'allais dire encore un peu soviétique
céder aux désirs
merci à vous jean de gliniasty je
rappelle quand vous êtes chercheur à les
riffs en fait un ambassadeur de france
en russie